Um, um, hello.
Um, hi.
Um, hello.
Wait, hold on, I'm moving.
I'm grabbing my mic and said, Oh, go ahead, Jinjama,
itchama, hello.
Look, though.
P&D but I have video in the background so that you will
still watch so that you will still you'll still be paying
attention yeah hello everybody um I'm in a hotel room so
there were many things that went wrong with this stream the
first being that I'm a hotel room and the second being that
oh my gosh the what's it called the the noise gate on this
thing is crazy how does it sound oh okay never mind the go
xlr program does not work so i actually can't update
anything so we're just gonna i sound loud we're just gonna
we're just gonna we're just gonna
we're just gonna do it I sound okay I sound fine okay um
what was I saying oh so I'm in the hotel room and um well I
was like I'm gonna test okay hold on let me explain hotel
struggles first um I was like okay I'm going to sign in to
get free wi-fi and then they were like oh sorry you can't
log in right now we're working on it i said okay cool then
i'll hot spot so i'm hot spotting and it might be bad
hopefully not bad though and then and then um and then
there's one plug by the desk and i need a plug for my laptop
and also for this USB hub that I bring with me so I need two
plugs and because I cannot plug in both I cannot also plug
in my camera for me to move and so I need two plugs And so,
because of that, hotel Wi-Fi is always a gamba.
Well, it shouldn't be.
Can't you plug your camera directly into your computer?
Great question.
I cannot do that because I only have two USB slots, and
that's why I need the USB hub, because I need to plug in my
GoAXLR, and I need to plug in my mouse, and I need to plug
in...
My phone.
USP.
Usp.
Yeah, I'm Metal Gear thinking about guns.
So...
You put Family Guy clips in the corner.
No!
They're gonna take me out.
This is Family Guy.
Hold on.
How's the song go?
uh um it seems today that all you see is violence and movies
and sex on tv wait hold on commercial 11 21 start but where
are those good old-fashioned values on which we used to rely
lucky there's a family guy lucky there's a man who can do
all the things that make us cry.
She's a family guy.
Ouch.
I'm like laying on the couch.
Not laying on the couch.
I'm sitting, but I threw my head back because I was laughing
and I hit my head.
have a feeling that it's gonna be a wonderful day that's the
superior show i like american dad way more than i like
family guy i think that's the superior show the sun in the
sky has a smile on face and a salute to the american verse
oh boy on tuesday good morning rosie
boys oh yeah shot b12 yeah i've been watching american down
in so long though
but um uh yeah so then that's why I'm a PNG I apologize but
I have some work that I need to get done that's why I
brought my laptop in the first place and my whole setup but
as you can see it's a little scuffed and I was like oh so
also I had bought a smaller version of my interface that I
use at the maid cafe be my travel interface this is
previously and then i used it at an event and it completely
like shot itself it was it was uh like i guess it's made
more for i'm i don't i thought i was using it correctly but
i guess it's made more for um like musical like playing
playing like if you're recording guitar and stuff and uh i
figured i was like you know if i ever do a collab like on
its own it was totally fine if i was doing a collab or
something it would like double the audio and things like
that so i was like okay well i'll get i'll get rid of it and
then um i bought the the mini go xlr which i have not had a
go xlr in an extremely long time yeah it was really awful
used it at MGS con and um it was you know I thought I had
the correct settings but there literally was no other
settings that I could try so I uh I I was like oh I'm so and
I felt so terrible because you know I was like I thought it
was the same as my interface at home but it just didn't have
enough channels of how I do my setup um didn't go or die i
yes but also they were like bought out question mark or
something what do i usually use i use i normally use a
yamaha ag08 and then they have the yamaha ag03 which is what
i had bought and i was like this is perfect it's exactly my
setup i know i like it i know i like i know how to use it
except it just doesn't work for my kind of streaming it like
I said it would be fine on its own it would just you know I
don't want to get something and then if I'm traveling you
know last time I traveled I had a collab with like Kiara and
Kobo and Ali so I was like wait wait was all wait am I going
crazy all he was in that collab right or am I insane right
now no wait who there was one other Wait, yes!
Yeah, okay, I was like...
Okay.
Because I remember, because I saw...
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I...
Okay, I remember why I was confused.
It's because I was thinking of Olly's default outfit.
But in the thumbnail, I used her like Otaku outfit.
That's why I was like, wait a second.
So, yeah.
So...
And so...
So, um, like, you know, I wouldn't have been able to do that
collab if I had the other interface, you know, things like
that.
I was like, I don't want to say no to stuff just because of
my interface.
So, so I got the Go XLR Mini instead, but right now, right
now it's giving me this error, DCP error.
to the most recent version, which I did.
It says, if firmware is up to date, try repairing the driver
with our driver repair wizard.
And I just really don't feel like doing that.
And it won't let me into the software to edit anything like
my voice or the noise gate.
So it might sound a little strange.
I apologize.
This is everything is just so scoffed.
I hope my phone's okay, being hotspot.
I pay per gig, so...
Um...
Uh, yeah, I pay...
I pay per gig, so...
Uh, I wonder what we're at.
Um...
Oh, my God, I'm watching the number go up.
Oh!
Guys, I might be cooked.
How much do you pay per gig?
$10?
But it caps.
It caps.
Google 5 caps at $80.
oh quick turn off the video here's a kick thank you no no no
i'm just gonna get rid of the number and not think about it
i'm just not gonna think about it everybody because because
i'm i wanted to be here and so that's why i made it happen
because i thank you guys thank you because i you know a
couple of days and i want to say hi and things have happened
if you didn't catch the twitter space and you're like what
the heck is this debut uh waiting room and what is the heck
is this this this video that is looping and den setu dot exe
what is this so
um yeah the the short version is the group that i was going
to debut with we decided to move forward with it um we're
having some help backing but we are still indie um we're not
corpo or anything i just have a manager now which is kind of
nice but um it's just the three of us we're just gonna do
our best and try and do cool things together and that's
that's that's it um things are still gonna be pretty same
for like all the content that i do and um uh so just
probably more like you know hopefully more shows hopefully
more uh opportunities um so yeah It's Steiner managing the
three of us.
Steiner is Phoebe's manager.
He's been managing her.
He's been very nice.
And very helpful.
But, uh, underground idol group.
That is probably the best way to put it.
It's like an underground idol group.
Is it actually just Steiner?
We do have a small team.
But, like, Steiner is, like, our main manager.
Hmm.
so which is kind of insane that like you know i've had
people be like yeah i used to read his blogs it's like can
you tell steiner we said he's cute um sure steiner's a
legendary localized i know it's crazy right so are you guys
going to game together too we will we will just you know
look forward to the three of us you know we'll be collabing
more together um it's just us being being fun gals so you
can look forward to girls being cute girls as always and and
a big deal is uh people you might be wondering why are they
all silhouettes well one we don't want to show you the cute
key visual art yet but also two vicky will be debuting
completely new she is she is it's her actual debut so you
know i'm the less important one here so victoria roman debut
this coming friday whoa i know finally and also there might
be some other surprises and we might you know you know we've
been working on some cool stuff for you guys very very
excited for the song so yeah yeah yeah yeah for me it's um
you know it says debut but it's really just a way to kind of
you know it'd be i feel if we i felt like it would be kind
of awkward to how do you say every the other two debut but
not me you know i'm already i'm already
so it's more like a like an introduction to to minto
reintroduction yeah so it's it is a group debut because we
are you know solidifying our name together and all jacquardo
happy birthday happy birthday happy birthday congratulations
Happy birthday with salutations, happy birthday, may your
sky stay blue, happy birthday to you, whoo, I'm sorry,
solidifying, Minto Gear Solid, ba-bam, yes, Minto Gear
Solid, always, always, congratulations on the big news,
Minto, I'm super happy for you, Victoria and Phoebe, Thank
you.
Support you in everything you do.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's all pretty much, everything's pretty much staying
the same.
Just a little bit of extra support in the back end and a
little, maybe a little shinier.
I have maybe some new updated things.
So, yeah.
It'll still be, it'll still feel a little bit new, but also
the same.
So that's it.
The dot EXE is pronounced dot EXE.
Ekuze.
Well, you can say the dot or you don't have to say the dot.
Just remember the dot is there.
Densetsu EXE.
Densetsu dot EXE.
It's pronounced like dot ink.
Ekuze.
Love EXE cover one, right?
What does Densetsu mean?
Densetsu means legend in Japanese.
We have a bit of a...
You'll see on the debut.
It's a little bit of a backstory.
so yeah yeah yeah legend
like umapyo identity yeah yeah yeah will you be singing make
you kumkum kudududun Friday night together we could I have
to I guess maybe hot spot funds more like hot pot funds hey
oh my gosh you guys we dinner today i went to went to three
different places and all of them were an hour wait i was
like oh my god an hour wait and then finally we went to i'm
hanging out with friends that's why i say we um but finally
we get to a restaurant and they're serving us and they're
like by the way um all of our stuff has been coming out 30
minutes late but did you guys end up having we had ramen
ramen ramen it was pretty tasty it was good but man i just i
just don't go out enough so i didn't think you know none of
us thought about making a reservation because we don't go
out to places typically and also i don't if i out to a place
i'm either one like getting takeout or two i am i am not i
am not there's not this many people you know crazy
coincidentally reading a manga about an undergrained
undergrained underground idol group let me make your
announcement wait which one can't control thank you so much
just make hot pot yeah if my hotel room had a stove maybe
hello minto from japan ducky i hope you're having fun hope
you had a good weekend weekend you too guys oh what's what's
what's been up what's going on wait i should start working
on work huh instead because we haven't talked in a couple
days.
That's why I just go to Cocoa Echi or Pepper Lunch.
Well, if I was in Japan, I would go to Cocoa Echi or Pepper
Lunch.
I'm not in Japan, you guys.
I'm not.
Good day, Minto.
I recently discovered you're single.
And I've taken to listening to it before work shift.
And it makes me happy.
Whoa!
Is this what being an idol fan is like?
my gosh thank you oh like welcome to mint cafe that's all
mint not in japan i know crazy i'm traveling and i'm not in
japan crazy i know my asayoru collab got sold out i'm i'm
i'm shocked i'm like I think, I think I was told that there
was concern about me selling out, so...
Or not me, but like, but like, you know, the event's selling
out.
So I was like, oh no!
You got a ticket, thank you!
Wait, one?
One?
One, one, no fan?
Or the useless idol and her only fan in the world?
So cute!
Sell out confirmed.
Yeah, I'm a sell out.
I'm selling out.
I'm a sell out.
Heard of that one.
Gone corporate.
Me.
Yeah, I'm a corporate shill.
Yeah.
life i'm returning back i'm that's that's gonna be my debut
is returning to being an office lady she's gone corporate
she's back in the office
she's when they say she's gone corporate it's real it's real
the cubicle calls no no no no please No, please, God, no,
God, no, please, God, I'm Michaeling, I'm Michael Scotting
right now, God, no, please, please don't make me go back to
the cubicle, I'll be a good ghost, I promise, I promise,
though I have thought about, like, you know, if I were to
get another job, you know, because I could just work in the
morning, and then stream at night.
That's what I used to do.
It's nothing that I couldn't.
Whoa, hi, Minto.
Working on debut stuff?
Yes.
Yes, I'm supposed to be working on debut stuff.
Would you ever even want to?
I have multiple thoughts about it.
them is like so i'm the kind of i'm the type that like even
if i won the lottery i would still want to keep a stable job
because i you know i like to have a key i like to keep my
work ethic in a in a way like i like to stay busy i like to
i like you know if i'm not working i i i don't feel
keeps you sane for real right job gives you structure right
right so there's that and then also like you know the it's
it's you know i i i rely very much on the generosity of you
guys to literally do anything and so to me you know if if i
could lesson that for you guys and just be funny you know
gush girl or like uh how to say um you know have something
to kind of you know keep things feeling stable obviously
everybody is there's there's many oh you guys are so
generous and kind to me and i i uh don't feel i deserve it
so i you know i um you know just that just me being like you
know with what if i had another job and then i could like
turn off super chats or something something like that you
know what i mean so so yeah just so that you know it's less
it's more or rather it's more like a
just here for the vibes here for the vibes yeah yeah yeah
obviously i do appreciate each and every one of you so thank
you very much and if you want to support me i of course
appreciate that so much and if you're just here to watch i
of course appreciate that so much as well so thank you thank
you thank you thank you
late right it is quite late I apologize but of course please
sleep if you need to sleep or if you're up late working with
me that is not good go to sleep
about 1 a.m.
4 a.m.
3 a.m.
oh my goodness you are the funniest I'm fine hi Pete Zimito
hello dusty dog thank you so much for the five gifted thank
you guys thank you guys for the for the super chats and
welcome back to membership the noise gate on this is kind of
insane wait I think it's because my computer is loud can you
hear this it's so loud oh my god I'm like close to the van
right now and it's so loud
sounded like a creeper breathing wait like what kind of
creeper like a minecraft creeper or what do we what do we
what do we we're like a kind of creeper you don't hear the
fan at all oh that's great
did you hear that that was the fan hold on Whoa.
That's audible.
Yeah, here I'll do it again.
Wait, it's kind of like, it kind of gives me like ocean
vibes, right?
Like, like you hear the ocean and it's kind of, it's kind of
soothing, right?
Yeah.
It's like old TV white noise.
Yeah, this is pretty good.
This is pretty good.
Wait, should I just...
When I am working on stuff, which I totally will do.
Should I just hold the mic up to the fan?
Huh.
It's not working now.
Okay.
Authentic office vibe?
No, no, no.
That would be like if I had like my boss coming up and being
like, Hey, Minto, you got that paperwork done for me yet?
That would be like, oh my God, please.
No, I'm working on it.
Is that what we sound like because we are fans?
I think you guys sound nicer probably.
10 out of 10 boss voice.
Hey, Minto, is that paperwork done yet?
What is a TPS?
What is that?
Wait.
TPS.
What is that?
T?
It's from office space.
What's office space?
What is office space?
Is that a game or a movie or a show or?
It's a great movie.
No, I've never seen office.
Hold on.
Where's my phone?
Oh, right here.
Don't look at the numbers.
What am I at even?
I'm so curious.
I want to look at the numbers.
Number go up.
Office space.
Movie, you guys said?
Office.
hmm oh it's old
what is this description corporate drone peter gibbons hates
his soul-killing job at software company in a tech while
undergoing hypnotherapy peter is left in a blissful space
when his therapist session he refuses to work overtime plays
game at games at his desk and unintentionally charms two
consultants into putting him on the management fast track
when peter's friends learn they're about to be downsized
they hatch a revenge plot against the company inspired by
superman 3.
what does that mean stop reading oh wait why it
sounds funny that's a good movie oh spoilers well i don't
understand what it what it means it was just a small
overview there's this one office box and office space that's
your typical yeah so we're gonna need you to write those TPS
reports after hours, thanks a lot, and then he sips coffee.
Ah, okay.
It's just a bit spoiler.
It's okay.
I don't understand it, so I don't think I got spoiled at
all.
Because I've never seen Superman 3.
So I've never seen Superman 3.
I'm safe, I'm safe.
Movie name, office space.
Guys, I'm so sleepy on this one.
It was directed by the creator of King of the Hill.
It's probably pretty good.
I am a yonder.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
It's really funny.
Deaf recommend for the former office gal.
I've worked several offices.
Actually, I'd say three and then no four.
Four offices.
Not four office jobs in my afterlife.
I've had many jobs.
I literally...
Okay, guys, I don't know if I've ever said this before
either, but like one time I got a job at a Japanese company.
and um i literally did that thing where the whole almost the
entire interview was in japanese and but it was a japanese
company in the united states and i literally did that thing
where it's like when you when you put your your when you
When you, when you, when you, when you put that you are
Nihongo Jozu, but, or like, you know, when you lie on your
resume, I literally did that.
And during the interview, they asked me questions.
And then I answered something.
And it totally got them on another tangent.
Because, so basically, I could not understand it all.
Like, I couldn't understand, like, the mechanical jargon
that they used.
But then they asked me another question, and I answered
that.
And then...
And then they started talking a lot.
And...
And then the interview was over.
And they were like, okay, cool, you got the job.
I did, I maybe spoke like three words in this interview.
Like,
I literally, it was just probably like, Oh, hi.
So they were like, You're hired.
Literally fake it till you make it.
But the job was kind of hell.
Because...
The entire...
Okay, so how do I explain?
I was like a middle...
Even now, I don't really understand what I got hired to do.
So like, how do I explain?
Okay, how do I explain?
It was like... Okay.
They kind of...
It was like shipping...
Parts?
to shipping like machine parts to other companies is like
the best way that i can describe it and so my job the girl
who trained me trained me for a week and then she was like
i'm out see ya and it was like uh logistics logistics Yes.
Yes.
Yeah.
My job, though, was to, to make educated guesses on how long
the things would take to arrive at the, at the company.
And I was like, how do you know?
And she would be like, well, you see, there's a boat.
and it literally is just vibes guessing the job and like i'd
be like okay and apparently she was like the best she could
guess things down to like a day or something she was so good
she was a prodigy I was like, well, how do you know?
And she was like, the boat comes.
And I'm like, okay, but like, yeah?
And she's like, you just have to feel it.
And I'm like, what?
And so then she left and I would be stuck there like,
what am I doing?
And, and, um, Safe to say, I didn't last very long.
There was like a whole spreadsheet of boats.
And you would have to like look at like the longitude and
the latitude of the boat.
And then be like, okay, this is where the boat is at.
And then guess.
And then fill out the spreadsheet.
like of like this is this is how long it will take before
it's there and you had people every day and she would just
the girl training me she would be like oh yeah like kumiko
sama she's crazy she will message you she will email you
every day asking how much longer and i just subtracted a day
because it's the next day So if it's 30 days, the next day
that she emails you, you say 29.
It just works.
That was a job that I had, you guys.
Like, a real job.
That was a real job that I had.
Oh, geez.
And they would get really mad at you if your predictions
were not correct about how long it would take for these
things to arrive.
Um, I feel like they trolled you or something.
It was very, I, it was, it was very, it was a very strange
job.
I wasn't as good as the girl that trained me.
She was a prodigy guesser.
She could just she like sensed it in her little brain.
She had like an antenna coming out of her head that could
communicate with the boat.
I heard fake it till you make it.
But never fake it till you fake some more.
It's yeah.
Yeah.
office meant be like hi so and yeah i guess like japanese
was not like a super requirement but they would talk to me
in in japanese and i'm like i'm i'm i'm literally slaving
away at my desk literally measuring latitude and longitude
of these boats and they're like Konnichiwa, Minto-san?
Gengi desuka?
And I'm like, down to like millimeters.
Maybe their question was, hmm, yeah, she looks like a
Kan-Kole fan.
You can sense the boat.
Yeah, they thought I had boat sense.
But the great part was, it was it was pretty close to the
old maid cafe that I was haunting.
So, um, so yeah it was a I yeah I was pretty close and then
it was it was a job yeah it was a job and I needed one yeah
yeah and I remember I had that job and I remember applying
for other jobs being like i can't do this i can't i am not a
boat psychic i can't do this i don't understand i'm not the
boat whisperer and so i was like putting in other job and i
remember i got a i finally had gotten a job uh at another
place that was like over an hour away and i took it because
of a commute.
And so I took that because that's how desperate I was to get
away from the boats.
I was desperate.
Oh, great Minto of the boat.
What is my numbers to win the lottery?
Give me your longitude and latitude right now.
And I got you, buddy.
I got you.
Out of morbid curiosity, how much did this job pay?
Great question.
I can't remember.
But I believe it was like 13, 14 an hour.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Full time.
I
still think it's badass that you hired with only three
words.
Thank you.
13 an hour in the 80s
whoa the coordinates I wonder where that shows
the 1800s hey how old do you think I am there were no maid
cafes in the 1800s Only real maids.
Oh my gosh.
Jay Hurton, thank you.
This was 20 minutes ago, but thank you so much for the
Akadono.
Just got back from my first Japan trip.
Thank you for all your recommendations.
Jam is probably my favorite maid cafe so far, and I will go
back again.
This is extra cash I managed to save from the claw machines.
Thank you.
Daily Dayo, thank you.
Speaking of going corporate, I'm being onboarded as a video
editor at a big company.
Thanks in part to so much practice editing Minto clips.
Oh, nice!
Good job.
To learn that Minto is once an office lady is pretty
appealing to me.
I love office lady aesthetic.
I've been office lady a couple times.
Yeah.
but I prefer maid I don't want to be I don't want an OL
outfit you guys I don't want to be reminded please you can
draw fan art though just don't I don't want to think about
me being an office lady please please don't make me do it
ah um um I didn't say Don't say that she wanted to get an
office job again Oh, and I didn't I don't think I said that
I wanted an office job per se I was thinking a job in
general Not just an office job Something I don't know Who
knows?
I might be too busy though We'll see Minto wanted to be a
grocer I'm gonna bag your groceries Wouldn't that be kind of
nice though If I'm bagging your groceries And I'm like, how
are you doing today?
When you're like, good?
And I'm like, wow, you sure are buying a lot of cheese.
Just shift the eyes.
Then you'd be like, you'd never come back.
I'd be like, hmm, someone's hungry.
it's it's for a party
yeah you would never come back she's so good at small talk I
know yeah what's my total if you say you're having a party
I'd be like can I be can I come over am I invited what are
you making with all the cheese Just put the cheese in the
bag, ma'am.
Put the cheese in the bag.
Put it in the bag.
Have you done retail before?
I have.
Yep, I've done retail before.
Um.
I quit right before I went on vacation because they didn't
approve it.
It was like a Christmas.
you know around christmas and i was going i had already
planned my trip and um they were like nah that's christmas
and i was like okay bye but right before i i quit right
before i left my boss had actually he got fired by corporate
because he was stealing money from the safe they caught him
so um things were a little topsy-turvy anyway Uh, I got out.
Yeah, so, you know.
It's a good thing you aren't office worker because we get to
be here with you.
Yeah.
Please input the barcode numbers into the computers
manually.
Oh, I had that as a job, actually.
Where, uh, I worked for a car insurance company.
That was another office job that I did.
will input every single carven into the system yeah that was
my job yeah data entry yep that was when it was that job
that i uh what's the word it was that job that um i would
listen to like audiobooks and so that's when i started like
listening to the really strange ones like the billionaire
boys club and I think also on that job I like yeah Minotaur
milking farm no that was that was just recreational but yeah
it was at my data entry job that I started listening to
audiobooks so
so Enzo Mancini!
Enzo Mancini!
I once had a job where my manager was blatantly stealing
money from the safe on camera without even thinking.
Or without even trying to hide it.
Not sure what he was thinking.
Yeah.
I wish I had such a storied history.
Really?
I don't know.
I've just had a lot of jobs.
You know.
Uh.
For as long as I can remember.
you know had to pay for my own stuff so always always
working
I'm just trying to get one you can do it you can do it I
know that it can be really tough especially with like how
I've heard sorry oh my gosh I just realized like we're
talking about the J word that's so scary we're talking about
jobs but you know um but uh what's the word you like things
right now are like so difficult because like offices will
put up like ghost positions or they'll like filter through
certain words or stuff like that it's kind of strange.
It's like a strange
time to apply for jobs, so, you know.
Don't be so hard on yourself if it's really tough, you know.
Hmm.
You know.
A lot of people are having a lot of trouble, so it's not
just you.
It's not just you.
You got this.
Hmm.
So many fake listings, too.
Yeah, I'm like, why?
I also had a data entry job plumbing equipment for an
aquaculture business.
I would also have to take the mail to the mailbox, which was
down a long dirt road.
I would race the company dog off foot.
What?
That sounds awesome.
If I buy a membership, is it going to renew every month?
It does.
It does renew every month.
But thank you, I appreciate you with the super chat.
And even considering the villainous dance.
Thank you so much for that gift.
And thank you.
Thank you for the
double-dif-d-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double
gifted.
Thank you.
Remember there was a fake post office jobs in my area.
No!
Double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double-double.
Double gifting.
Double dipping.
Don't double dip.
That's nasty.
You gotta be san- You gotta be sanitary.
Guys.
I didn't get any work done.
I just have too much fun talking to you guys.
I just have so much fun.
I missed you guys.
I'll try to stream tomorrow as well productive evening we're
catching up
can we catch an out can we catch an out well thank you
though you know for very impromptu the impromptu stream and
what's the lord you know hanging out with me i really
appreciate it i miss you guys but i'll be back oh well i'll
see you tomorrow and then also stuff this week debut then
tattoo.exe and uh yeah
I hope you guys have a good rest too.
What is the debut anyway?
You're already here.
Oh, I explained it at the beginning of the stream, but I'll
say it again.
Basically because Vicky and Phoebe are debuting, I am
also...
be kind of weird for only the two of them we're kind of like
just doing it as like a formality it's really just to be
like look at us you know we're we're a group now we're group
together and uh and it's kind of like you know and just like
an introduction to me so yeah showing camaraderie
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
New model.
If only.
The debut was supposed to happen so long ago that I was
supposed to debut my second outfit at it.
Like, that's how long ago it was supposed to happen.
So.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
Everything.
I feel, I feel, we're, you know, we're just chilling.
I mean, we're not chilling.
We are working hard.
But it almost feels like we're chilling just because it's
like, you know, we have had a lot of time to hang out and
get to know each other.
And we're just, we're just all goofy together.
So, to me, it, it.
almost feels like chilling because i'm like i'm feeling like
relaxed with them because they're my friends so yeah yeah
yeah maybe i'm just also feeling relaxed in the moment
because i'm sleepy so i'm like you know i'm very excited but
i'm also like yeah he's cute
It's cute.
We're vibing.
Yeah.
So that hopefully, if that didn't explain it completely, you
can listen at the beginning of the stream.
Yeah.
Fun times ahead.
So.
Hope you're still having fun even though it's work.
I'm having so much fun.
can't wait for you guys to see the work that is happening at
the very moment um but i always still feel bad that like i
i've been talking to other people about it recently just
like when i'm gone for when i when i leave for when i have
to like you know leave my maid cafe to go do work outside
like the guilt is that you know i can't stream i'm working
but i can't stream so it feels like i'm not working and so
it's it's like a it's like a weird you know obviously like
i'm doing stuff but you won't see it for like a long time
from now so oh my gosh unreal citizen thank you so much for
the akashama thank you so it's like a strange feeling how
like it's like you know i'm doing stuff but it's not
streaming for me streaming always remains my number one
priority and that will continue you know that's why i bring
my laptop when i'm traveling and things like that so even if
it's like a little one-hour yapping session it still is you
know just something to you know talk to you guys say hi give
you company if you want a background stream or anything like
that so that's why i'm very uh let's you know it's not
everybody's mindset but it's definitely my mindset
yeah yeah yes yes the stream refreshed me fully really talk
about logistics and cheese
but also i've talked about this with people too i feel like
especially to do these kinds of yapping sessions like back
when i did have my my office job i would go out and i would
do things and i would have stories to talk about you know
it's like i can only tell my my five-year-old stories so
many times before you know obviously there's always going to
be someone new in chat that's never heard a story before but
you know there's there's only so many times i can reuse
these old stories so i have to go out and and experience
things so that i have new things to tell you guys and talk
to you about you know what i mean so it's it's a bit of a
balance it's a bit of a balance it's kind of like a strange
thing that you know i'm also thinking about
new hauntings exactly why do you always have to stream when
i'm sleeping i'm sorry that's just that's just about
schedule gotta go live your life but i'm not living what do
i i gotta go That's what it would feel like to be living.
Live your afterlife?
You gotta go after live.
Exactly.
Just a little bit sometimes.
But that's also sometimes why I play so many games and don't
do very many like talking streams is because Because I'm
like, oh gosh.
Sometimes I'm, you know, I'm like, what if I run out of
things to talk about?
I don't know.
When I play game, I can talk about game.
I now curse you with...
What did you curse me with?
With an interesting afterlife.
No!
Saving up stories for the winter like nuts.
Oh my gosh, I saw a fat squirrel.
that guy was huge i'll be like i also saw a squirrel that
was in a trash can and he was like poking his head out and
eating from the trash can and i was like you think you think
you're you think you're the king of this place get out of
there squirrel
I don't know what it is.
I think those guys are funny.
Good night, Minto.
Thanks for the stream.
Good night.
Can you say Jaguar?
Why?
Get a job as a chicken nugget expert.
Now, what makes an expert on chicken nuggets?
The first thing that popped into my head was like finding
chicken nuggets that resemble shapes of things.
You know, like I could be an expert and say like this
chicken nugget definitely looks like a picture of Michael
Jackson.
And people would look at it and be like I see Michael
Jackson
Abraham Lincoln Yes
Yes Oh my gosh That would be like a fun museum Going to a
museum of preserved foods That look like things or people
but like not like a dino nuggy that is shaped into it but
like they just took it out of the bag and wham bam thank you
maam that is uh that's Keanu Reeves Jesus on toast the
museum of Jesus toast
where Where would they source this from?
They're all donations!
Donate to your local arts!
We're a museum!
I'm starting this right now.
Have you ever had a food item that looks like something?
Give it to me right now.
So I can preserve it in its best state.
And then display it in my museum of oddities.
Of chicken nugget shapes.
and other food items.
Chicken nugget shapes that look like people or things and
other food items.
That's the name of my museum.
Haunted Jesus Toast would be a museum of haunted Jesus
Toast.
Do you not remember that each chicken McNugget had an avatar
that represented them?
What?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
What is that?
Pizza with pineapple.
We can't, we're not just, we're not just, we're not just
putting pizza with pineapple in the museum.
We have standards.
Cheetos shaped like a dragon.
Thank you.
Yes, we accept it.
Please donate.
Please send it to me right now.
Please send me your Cheeto in the shape of a dragon.
That will be our, that will be our, uh, our monthly main
exhibit.
in fact oh my gosh oh my gosh wait hold on what if what if
you found um like how many are there of those stone warrior
statues what are they called the terracotta the terracotta's
army the terracotta soldiers What if you found...
Like...
What if you found like...
Hmm...
A hundred Cheetos that looked like...
You found a hundred individual Cheetos that looked like...
Wait.
And each one looked like a terracotta soldier.
And then you displayed them.
that's that's just as interesting as going to the real thing
no in fact i would say it's maybe more impressive because
you would have to dig through hundreds of thousands maybe
even millions of cheetos to find enough to create a
terracotta army replica army next cam stream I open, I open
1,000 bags of Cheetos looking for one that looks like one
terracotta army soldier.
The chance is not zero.
Exactly!
And that's why, that's why it's going to be my mission.
I'm going to become a terracotta army soldier, Cheeto
soldier, finding.
YouTube account.
This is actually what my new debut is.
I'm rebranding.
The reason why it's a silhouette is because literally my new
model is a Cheeto.
My whole new look?
Cheeto.
I look like a, like a gosh darn cheesy puff.
rebranding stream need to get some sleep now I'm going to
the Gundam base early tomorrow good night, Minto have fun
have fun your boat guessing job amplified your psychic
guessing powers you've got this thank you oh well, thank you
so much for the ping Patrick, oh boy 4 a.m.
time for some Minto drop to say hi I'm back to sleep Good
night.
Mint, would you accept this potato chip I just found?
Like Haley Joel Osman.
Nope.
Well, hmm.
And everyone says I have terrible ideas.
Huey!
Shut up.
I guess I have to accept anything.
But anything that resembles Haley Joel Osman would go, okay,
you know how Zach Baggins has his museum of haunted things?
and it's like you have to sign a waiver to go in and you
have to like you know spooky things might happen to you this
is the same exact thing if you were to view it's like okay
it's like you see the haley joel osman chip potato chip it
might be like the movie from the ring and you might have
seven days and you might die after you look at it it's
literally just basement exhibit room for Haley Jalazment
food it might it might just be like an actual cursed object
the Haley Jalazment Cheeto is a biohazard yes literally to
even handle it I need to be in a hazmat suit special glasses
Haley Jalazment Cheeto potato chip would belong that would
just be an SCP
what did he do to you to be cursed well his face is just a
little too small for his big fat head and it makes me really
uncomfortable and that's why I don't like him hmm
hmm that's about it I do remember you saying that before.
He can't help it.
Give him a second chance.
You're streaming with HotSpot?
Oh yeah.
Let me see what the number's up to.
Oh, it's actually less than I thought.
I'm almost at 13 gigs.
That's not so bad.
I started at 2.
so I've streamed about 11 gigs in an hour
yeah actually it's it's not so bad I thought it was gonna be
like at 80 or something crazy
nice nice how hot is my phone not even she's spicy
expensive stream yeah the things I do for love
but I am really tired now it's almost midnight so I'm gonna
I have to get ready for bed and I have to wake up early
tomorrow more stuff to do but thank you guys for this fun
time letting me in chit chat with you all and everything
yeah um hopefully i could stream again tomorrow and dorko
thank you so much for that pink thank you if you dream of
goat heads dream of them as office stooges yeah um thanks
for hanging out with me for a little bit it was quite nice
And I will talk to you guys.
I'm going to talk to you next.
Yeah.
Latiminto, everybody.
Hopefully this was relaxing enough.
So that you could, like, listen to it.
And feel chill.
You know?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, in a second.
Oh, there we go.
Latiminto, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will see you when I see you next.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye-bye.